if you watch the Gustafson john jones
fight - John late in that fight
did you know there could have been some
doubt in some people who's winning that
fight or whatever was close fight but
look like John just started pouring it
he was 3 2 1 you know strikes in the
last couple rounds yeah the last rounds
won him that fight and by all accounts
John wasn't in shape by all accounts
John really didn't train for that fight
and didn't take Gustavsson seriously and
gonna half-assed his training camp and
still pulled it off in the championship
rounds that guy's I mean and they're
gonna rematch that's it there right yeah
that's January yep the December card
it's January
New Year's Eve you know basically I
think it's the December 29th a fantastic
fight and cuz I think Gustafson's way
better now you see when Gustafson
knocked out clover to share I mean he
just looked like there was like a video
game controversial yeah so I think that
fight is that's that's gonna be one for
the ages and then for John be his
comeback fight and forgot stuff sin to
be the rematch he's asking for forever
and it will be for the light heavyweight
title they're gonna strip Cormier are
they gonna fight
yeah I mean he's gonna he's fighting
Derrick Lewis in December a weird fight
well Brandon he's number t really I mean
it's if you look at the rankings it's
not if you look at Derek Lewis is
obviously unorthodox but he was just
getting mauled in that last fight it
doesn't matter when I guess then man I'm
gonna get that last punch in well it's
so the power that he has with his finger
you know why am I even talking about man
yeah I mean he really was the number-two
contender headed into that fight and
then wins I think that guy was the dark
horse of division yeah and so for him to
knock all Alexander like that I mean
that's a jet was a giant knockout yeah
and to get his ass kicked for three
rounds respect to to Alexander though
yeah for for staying in the pocket
fighting out with 30 seconds to go when
he was clearly winning that fight well
he got hurt he got hurt a couple times
in that fight did he do yeah yeah there
was one time where he lost his
mouthpiece and he tried to give it to
Derek yeah that's right I think he was
on queer Street I mean I don't think he
knew what the [ __ ] was going on cuz
Derek hit so hard
you don't get knocked out you're
probably like Oh even a glancing blow
right hey you probably what in the [ __ ]
I mean think about the way he knocked
out Travis Browne the way he knocked out
Gonzaga and Derrick would be even better
if you didn't have a bad back
Derek's got a fucked-up back so why does
he want it that's three fights in six
months or more the last fight with an
gone Oh